so what's the drive then what is the
ultimate goal
that is a great question
but the honest answer is I don't know
and I'll just speculate it may be there
are two directives of answers that I've
thought about and and that I'll say by
another problem with both of those
directions so One Direction would be to
say
um
the Ultimate Reality is love
but
to really love
um
you need something to love and so the
one intelligence projects itself into
multiple avatars
so that it has a chance to
learn to love and to practice love
so that's one idea so the reason for
making all this variety of headsets is
for the one to learn to love that's an
interesting direction that a friend of
mine Perry pasaro suggested that to me
as we were talking about your question
um and that and again I'm not saying
well I'll say why I think
there's a deeper problem here but the
other is to say you know uh this is more
from the exploration side of things is
to say well girdles incompleteness
theorem tells us there's an infinite
variety of mathematical structure to
explore infinite
it's endless and that means there's an
infinite variety of conscious
experiences to explore infinite right
yeah and so maybe that's what so
Consciousness is exploring all of its
infinite possibilities and saying let me
try on this headset and maybe you know
three dimensions of space one
dimensional time which is what we've got
is a fairly
rudimentary right this is why we think
of ourselves as sort of the exalted we
if we could look at the big picture we
might realize no no this this is a
particularly simple headset try the 50
billion Dimensions headset well you
think that chocolate tastes good hang on
a second hang on a second exactly
exactly full body orgasm with this
chocolate here you go that that's right
or you thought orgasm was something wait
till you see this
right right
one is about
um just the the fun of exploration but
in talking about this with a friend of
mine Annika Harris
um
who's uh you know she's got a book
called conscious and she's she's uh she
thinks very deeply about Consciousness
um
and what I was talking with you just a
week or so ago over lunch about this
very topic she said you know that that's
effectively she said it's too Romantics
she met too anthropocentric
those both of those kinds of
explanations may not they may be the
best kind of ideas that we can have from
our point of view of avatars in space
and time but they and and they're good
but but we shouldn't cling to those
either the I mean there's probably
something even far deeper than that I
think your point is well taken but
nevertheless I think it's worthwhile to
put out these romantic ideas these
human-centric ideas
if for nothing else to have them as
foils so that we can go deeper and find
deeper answers to that to your question
when we go to the first one about love I
think you also mentioned something about
there being a lot of basically it seems
harmonic and peaceful so how do you know
love if you don't have the opposite are
polarity is fundamental
to Evolution even if it means just the
next level of awareness like how do you
know this without that right that's
that's a really good question what why
does the unbounded intelligence decide
to drop into these smaller Realms of
polarities right because in some sense
there is no opposite of love
what love just is and yet here we have
um what we might call clinging and not
clinging which is sort of our our our
polarities that we call love um in the
human sense although there is that you
know a Mother Teresa kind of love that
isn't the kind of clinking right there
is that deeper kind of love that that is
possible but much of what we call love
is not it's it's more clinging or or
you know or eventually running away from
somebody
so sometimes they do so yeah sometimes
and and I
that is an incredibly deep question
which is
why does
the young bounded intelligence
plunge itself into these avatars
yeah
the I mean the kinds of things we
sketched about
learning to love and exploring all the
possibilities
somehow I feel like I'm up against the
limits of my current abilities with that
question uh just that's that's as far as
I've gotten this and I don't know how to
go further which except just to go into
silence and and see what comes out of it
that's beautiful I love the honesty of
that that's that's um that's the right
answer okay it's kind of like sort of
wrap up at least what's going on within
our realm right now that seems like
something kind of interesting that I'm
just curious what your thoughts are and
how it will play into all this is just
um AI you know I know that that was
something of interest to you initially
um going into artificial intelligence to
understand things so
um do you think that that you know what
what's the best case scenario that and
what's the worst case and you know how
could that help us in our Evolution and
is AI actually our Evolution like is do
you believe that Consciousness can be uh
do you think that an artificial
intelligence can adopt Consciousness and
can have one right so the standard way
that that question is asked is from a
physicalist framework most of my
colleagues who are thinking about it are
saying space and time is fundamental
matter is fundamental matter is not
Consciousness it matters not conscious
itself but the idea is if you have
the right kind of complexity in the
interactions of matter so the right kind
of neural circuitry or the right kind of
artificial intelligence software somehow
the unconscious ingredients will give
rise to consciousness so integrated
information theory for example is one
Theory along that line
where they think that
some there's if a system has some kind
of functional property they call
Integrated information
the right kind of integrator information
then it will give rise to Consciousness
Consciousness or orchestrated collapse
of microtubule States or something
called a global neuronal workspace so
there's different ways where you have
some substrate
now integrated information Theory people
can say well they don't have to assume
space-time but they're going to assume
some substrate the substrate that's not
conscious yeah and if it's not physics
what is it that they haven't said but
anyway
so
they're trying to say that the
artificial intelligence Consciousness
would emerge from unconscious
ingredients
and I'm saying that the physicists are
telling us that those ingredients don't
even exist when they're not perceived
they can't give rise to Consciousness
because they don't have the power local
realism is false so the Nobel Prize is
given this week local realism as false
is time for our theories of
Consciousness to recognize that local
realism is false physical objects do not
exist when they're not perceived so they
could not create Consciousness so that
version of you know artificial
intelligence giving rise to
Consciousness is dead
if you can't work nevertheless I think
that if we we can get at it from a
different angle okay our
perceptions of space and time and
objects is a user interface to this
realm of conscious agents in our current
in my current theory so right now
um
I see through a zoom screen I see pixels
of your fix those pixels are not
conscious or unconscious yeah so I also
see pixels of of a wall behind you and
your face is giving me insight into your
Consciousness I'm getting an insight
into what you think what you're worried
about what you're excited about
but the pixels on the wall give me no
insight into Consciousness so
my interface gives me portals into
Consciousness the good portals are
things we call human bodies or my cat
the cat body is a fairly Good Portal
into some Consciousness not as good as
human and disease is a worse portal a
microbe is even worse and by the time we
get down to rocks and so forth the
portal is closed I'm always interacting
with Consciousness but my interface has
to give up that's what interfaces do
they're dumbing things down so if at
some point they just have to throw up
their hands and say I can't tell you
more about the conscience Consciousness
is far too complicated I'm just going to
show you a rock there is consciousness
by the way it's not that the rock is
conscious
right I'm not saying the rock is
conscious the rock is just my symbol so
the rock is my perception behind that
symbol behind outside of space and time
there's Consciousness I'm interacting
with and the best I can do is come up
with a rock that's just my imagination
got it
so so that's where we're stuck so that
that means if we can understand how
these portals work if we understand so
we know one way that we can make new
portals into Consciousness we do there's
one way we know how to do it it's very
low Tech okay it's having kids oh ah
okay right every time you have a kid
you're booting up a new interface of
Consciousness right do you have kids I I
have a a daughter and three grandkids oh
wow so it's it's sister has four or
fourth on the way so I'll have to live
through those guys probably
congratulations
so so
suppose that we understand this notion
of portal right what's going on here
that allows me to have access to your
Consciousness not complete but but
genuine access yeah and vice versa
whereas it's less to a cat and less to
an aunt right the portals if we
understand though our user our
perceptual interface space and time is
an interface that way and these portals
and I think we can I think there's no
obstruction mathematically
once we do that then we should be able
to engineer new portals and it may turn
out that when we do that
some of the portals will have will look
like artificial intelligences
but it won't be that
unconscious
matter somehow gave rise to
Consciousness no it will be that
conscious agents
learned how their interface worked and
reverse engineered their interface to
open up new portals into already
existing consciousnesses but we're
already there
the technology may look like artificial
intelligence would probably look like a
lot of other things too once we really
understand this so my attitude is yes we
will eventually be able to create new
portals not just the old-fashioned way
through having kids but we'll be able to
do it technologically so and
um
but it will not be unconscious matter
creating Consciousness it'll be
Consciousness opening up new portals
into itself
[Music]